all right our next guest is one of the
top three athletes in his family maybe
top five we'll see he was an academic
all-american at Stanford which is not an
Ivy League school communications major
late academic all-american for
communications really he's been called
sneaky fast his whole life and maybe
someday he'll graduate too just fast
please welcome Christian McCaffrey
kind of kind of walked on staring me
down there what was that your game face
no I'm excited I'm excited to be back I
appreciate you having me back
are you still sneaky faster you know
fast always be sneaky fast gym rat smart
guy Oh coach's son yeah coach's son yeah
yeah what do people say on the street to
outside of Carolina and like just
walking around here not much not much I
can I can get by you know there's a lot
of guys in the league we're very
recognizable it's getting it's getting
to where I'm you know I'm getting more
recognizable but I can get away pretty
well without you know without getting
bug but so you can just walk down the
street and people just blend in I ride a
longboard it's a practice everyday a
little electric scooter boosted board
yeah I ride that to practice everyday no
one no one says a word but people are
really nice too and in Charlotte they're
very respectful and of your space and a
new time and so it's you know the
southern hospitality sometimes that's it
that's it - but where is your team right
now and moving forward I know you bring
in an offensive coordinator and a new
coach but Luke Kuechly is retiring and
Greg Olsen is retiring you don't know
what Cam Newton is doing like it says
does it feel like a rebuild yeah yeah
definitely you know new coaching staff a
lot of new players you know
unfortunately a lot of guys like Luke
and Greg weren't gonna be with us
anymore you know it's it's the sad
reality of the NFL you know you know
coming in I'm thinking I'm gonna play
with these are my best friends I'm gonna
play with in my whole career and going
into year four and it's like you know
everybody's kind of going separate ways
it's it's it's the sad reality of the
league but you know I'm very fortunate I
got to play with guys like Greg guys
like Luke who you know now
only obviously they're great players but
great people and good friends and will
be lifelong friends so you know I gotta
have to sit back and appreciate that you
know I got the practice against guys
like Luke Kuechly every day did he ever
hit you you know he's an unbelievable
practice player so he takes care of his
guys he never maybe we I mean we would
do one-on-one Pass Pro and camp and we'd
go out a little bit there but I mean
he's the model pro pro football player
you know I did it the right way you know
was never dirty was never cheap had a
million tackles and you know somebody
that's very easy to emulate
McLovin says the tackles are overrated
in the NFL that tackles our tackles are
well because if you have a million
tackles that means the other team had a
million offensive snaps you're not
getting them off the field
so like the bet you know the leading
tacklers are not always do you want to
you want him not to tackle the guys
[Laughter]
competitor I would rather them tackle
the guys than not I don't think they're
overrated now by the way he went to
Dartmouth well if it's the other team I
like your theory though I will don't
want them to talk to more of like an Ivy
League stat dance I'll stay out of the
conversation Stanford's mom had dropped
out so I
it's like a state school right now a
safety school yeah did you get your
degree I did not know my mom reminds me
of it about every week that I'm a
college dropout so I hear enough yeah
but you get an honorary degree from
Stanford Kent I'll go back I'll go back
and get it I had plan a which was to
play in the NFL and I haven't had a plan
B so I'm still focusing on plan a okay
but communications yep
they they offer that at Stanford they do
are you they do yeah and I went full
headfirst into communications but what
do you want to do with them play
football and this is honest you know
it's so hard you know not that people I
had teammates who were management
science and engineering majors who were
physics majors and you know I would be
at practice feeling great really
energetic and they would show up I was
up all night you know on a piece and I
you know he just chose different paths
but you know I I was no but no in all
seriousness I I did study hard and it
Stanford is a they do not give a whole
lot of leeway to their athletes as far
as you know they're your grades go so
that's something that makes the school
so great they do have a high standard so
if not Stanford where would you have
gone that's that's a good question I
would have gone to the University of
Northern Colorado to play your dad play
for my dad yeah so they started I hope
so
now my brother played at Duke I was
highly considering Duke my older brother
played there you know a lot of the
pac-12 schools were the schools that
offered me I didn't have you know I
think Vanderbilt offered me in the SEC
and that was it so it was pretty much
pac-12 ER or Duke do you think that a
running back has a certain number of
touches you know that that's it that
your body has a number I don't think so
I mean every player has has a life span
you know no matter what position you
play you know there's guys look at
Adrian Peterson you know he's done it
forever he's young at a high level
forever there's guys who you know do it
for eight years there's guys that do it
for 14 I think it all comes down to the
individual on how you take care of
yourself had to hear your body and and
mentally how much you're you're you know
willing to go and you know a guy like
Luke Kuechly played eight years but like
I said he did have so many tackles in
the amount of you know touches and
tackles that he had is equivalent to
most people's 13 year span and but I
don't know if there's like a magic
number I think it's just a feel thing
for that certain individual what was
your welcome to the NFL moment
welcome to FL moment maybe you know I
it's a big you know it's it's it's a big
deal when you walk into the locker room
for the first time and you know you see
all these different guys but when I
stepped on the field my first run play
was the outside zone right to Julius
Peppers side and you know they called it
right there and I line up and I and I I
think I just looked over there and and
he's he's big everyone knows he's big
but if you've never seen him in person
you don't understand and and so I went
and I ran I mean it nothin ended up
happening but I think I got a jog back
to the to the sidelines like I just ran
you know right at Julius Peppers in
practice I was seven when he got drafted
and so that that was a welcome to the
NFL moment like I'm
we playing with guys like this now so
but but honestly I mean I I expected to
be there and and I don't know if I was
ever I got fortunate my dad played in
the lead for so long I got forced and I
got to learn from him and you know kind
of understand how it all works who's the
best athlete in the family my mom mom's
best athlete in the family I have to say
that but it's also true wait did she
really cry when you were born that's a
true story if you ever have around the
[ __ ] he'll tell you the story she
cried when she had me knocking she was
happy because she knew she was never
gonna have a girl and she was right you
know it's my three brothers and myself
so I guess that was her she just knew at
that point she's like I'm never gonna
have a girl and she really wanted a girl
who did you have on your wall poster
wise I had so many guys meet me and all
my brothers we were big fans of putting
the know that the Sports Illustrated
pictures on the wall of you know certain
athletes and stats and basketball and
football and baseball whatever it was
but I had just about every running back
you can think of all the Broncos guys
back in the day just when my dad played
so there's a whole bunch of them how
good were you at basketball I could play
you know I mean I yeah I could play I
was good I was good enough to get a
couple you know d2 offers and you know
play it we had a pretty good high school
team played AAU my whole life I loved
basketball to death so I was alright not
bad
you ever meet Kobe I never did I never
got the chance to unfortunately but that
I mean what a legacy that that he has
and one of the saddest things in the
world it still doesn't feel real but you
know I I have nothing but respect for
him and everything that he's done and my
prayers are with him and his family and
everybody affected you know all the
other families affected in that tragedy
you know it's a very sad sad deal but
you know I let you try to look at the
positive in every situation and I think
one thing I've learned
from it is as you see how one person
United the entire world you know he's a
global hero and I think it changed a lot
of people's perspective on how precious
life is and how we really need to
appreciate every single moment so I'm
very fortunate I got to watch it and
play basketball and watch him you know
live his life and in to see he's done
Christian McCaffrey joining us on behalf
of Old Spice there I was gonna say it's
not often when you say to another man
you smell good but when I walked over to
you I say you smell good you know do you
wear deodorant for a game not for the
game no not for the game I don't you
don't smell too good in the game people
start to wonder what you're doing but ya
know doing doing a lot with Old Spice
they just dropped their their new line
so they have it in a body wash and and a
deodorant so I mean after these spin
moves they might need one I
than the most athletic thing they've
done their whole life could my four guys
tackle you do you think today's tackle
me
no no why keep her on the football field
and those four guys who there oh they
couldn't tackle you know I mean pause
for a moment there no yeah yeah McLovin
I just saw the I just saw that anyway
and I also know you do some stuff with
the military yeah if you'd like to
mention that as well yes I you know
every year I do something with the
military it's something that you know as
far as to philanthropy goes I have a big
heart for veterans and for all of our
active-duty military and so I'm sending
active-duty marine this year to the
Superbowl him and his brother any chance
I haven't had a chance to get back and
partner with whoever I can actually we
did it with USAA did a good job of you
know helping me out there and and it's
fun for me because I like talking these
guys and learning from them and picking
their brains so you know I'm excited
about it and hopefully in the future you
know what we'll do a lot a lot bigger
stuff that hopefully can really impact
the military community but anytime I get
a chance to do something like that I
have fun with it and I know they did too
did you meet Jordan down in Charlotte I
have never I'd never met him either
I need to get out more well why don't
you go to a game I've been to a game but
I just didn't meet him at the game oh
yeah so why don't you leave a ticket for
him for an NFL game yeah you think he
needs tickets to go to the no no it's
the gesture yeah yeah you're right that
should be like a I'm gonna leave two
tickets for Mike and they'll get Mike
yeah Mike Mike Jordan worst-case
scenario people like Dan Christian those
[Laughter]
good luck with Old Spice and of course
the salute to service military
appreciation any well this is great to
see Christian McCaffrey we'll take a
break for more Dan Patrick show tune in
the audience channel 239 on DirecTV
streamed for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]